what's up youtubes welcome back to my
channel Richard on data my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about data so it's almost the end
of the year now and I'm beginning to
wrap up and just close out some of my
own personal projects before everybody
leaves for the holiday break so I wanted
to share the things that are in my
opinion anyway the absolute most
egregious things that I've done in my
career so far and the idea is whether
you're in data science or you're in
really any other field you are going to
learn new things every single month and
with that comes making mistakes and
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that as long as you're constantly
getting better and learning from your
mistakes and improving every time so I
do want to share these things in the
hope that you and your job learn from my
failures and do not repeat these
mistakes yourself
now before I get into these items as
always I would ask that you guys smash
the like button leave a comment down
below and then hit the subscribe button
if you haven't already then hit the
notification bell so you never miss an
update mistake number one is not
checking your work and your assumptions
as you go this is hands-down the worst
mistake that I've ever made and this is
the one that at best it could lead you
to some really uncomfortable
conversations with people at worst it
will lead to the most horrible stress
and worst work-related emails that
you're ever gonna send and the sad thing
about it is it's a lot easier to do than
you might think
now the reason this is so easy to do is
because literally every single line of
code that you write carries with it some
amount of assumptions and that's true
even if you're doing really basic stuff
like joining or filtering or grouping
all of it almost has some kind of
assumption associated with it so what
ends up happening is you'll have a big
long piece of analysis but it's easy to
miss some mechanical details in the
middle so just to give some examples
maybe you have a binary variable and
it's inverted somehow so the 1
represents what you think the 0
represents and vice-versa maybe you're
doing some
kind of filtering and the schema isn't
doing what you intended it to do you
could have conditional logic that's
really complicated and has a lot of
nests to it and then something in the
middle is off those are just some
examples but that's to illustrate the
idea that these things can happen in the
middle of your analysis and go
completely overlooked unless you
proactively try to catch them so how do
you prevent something like that from
happening well if you're like me you're
a super visual person and it's really
helpful to work in an integrated
development environment like our studio
where it's super easy to look and see
your data so every now and then just
visually inspect your data and make sure
nothing looks off or really weird in it
it's also really helpful up front to
list all of your assumptions and then as
you're doing your work just go through
and when you come up with something that
to you represents a massive assumption
add it to that list something else you
could do maybe is run summary stats on
your most important variables just make
sure everything is there you don't have
a lot of weird missing data
there's no values in there that you
don't expect just basic inspections like
that can save you a ton of time and a
lot of stress in the long run something
else that you could do is create a
working list of Diagnostics and tests
that you run that way you remember that
you check these things and that way
you're good to go you can even share
something like that with your client if
you do that I can almost guarantee they
will appreciate the quality of your work
and your attention to detail mistake
number two is not commenting code
thoroughly and I think this is something
that a lot of you can relate to because
nobody likes commenting their code
however commenting your code is a super
important thing to do and the biggest
reason for that is because you're often
going to be working in a team and you're
going to have to share your code with
someone else maybe they're going to
review it maybe they're going to add
things to it it could be for any reason
but your code is generally some kind of
byproduct of your own thought process
that's not necessarily something some
else we'll be able to follow so if
things are commented it's really easy
for them to get confused and possibly
frustrated trying to figure out why you
did something a particular way or what
you're doing in the first place it's
super important for your own benefit too
so data science projects evolve
constantly and it's not at all untypical
for your clients to hit you up two to
three days later after you've turned
something in and then ask you something
or ask you to make some changes it could
be anything and it's happened to me
before where I've gotten lazy with my
own commenting just because I wanted to
get through something and I figure well
I'll just comment all this at the end
and then I forget to do the actual
commenting then I go back to my own code
two or three or however many days later
and I've forgotten why I did something
or why I did something a particular way
so it'll save you a ton of time just
comment as you go it's not fun but it
will save you so much time in the long
run now the third biggest mistake that
I've made is not making analysis plans
now this is when you get a task from
your client that's bigger in nature and
then you think I don't need to make a
plan for anything I'm just gonna start
building crap so this one could depend
on your personality at least to a
certain extent me personally I love
building and creating and pushing things
through to completion but I don't
necessarily enjoy the act of actually
planning things and the problem that
you're gonna run into is that a data
science project or analysis necessarily
is going to have a lot of different
steps to it so it's super important to
keep yourself organized that's
particularly true when you're dealing
with large multidimensional types of
data sets there's absolutely nothing
worse than making some headway on a
project and then getting confused and
forgetting what the next step is it's
inefficient and it costs you a lot of
time and it's something that you can
prevent by just making a simple analysis
plan upfront and it doesn't have to be
something super complicated just maybe
take your text editor so it could be our
studio pycharm
Microsoft sequel server just whatever
you're working in literally list out the
things that you're going to do in the
order that you're going to do them
before you start writing code just
keeping your thoughts organized like
that is really gonna help you out and
save you a ton of time mistake number
four that I've made is over-promising
and under-delivering and now this one
happens because by its very nature data
science tasks can be extremely difficult
to estimate particularly if it's someone
else trying to estimate the amount of
time it'll take you to do a particular
task it's super easy particularly once
you get really good at certain things to
get tasked with something and then you
think oh this is super easy all I have
to do is clean this data set or apply
this analysis that I've done before to
some other data set maybe change some
names and some variables around just
simple stuff like that you see it in
your own head and think that it's going
to take a lot less time than it actually
does because I guarantee you what will
end up happening is something
unanticipated or weird and your data
will show up and then you have to spend
time figuring out what's going on as a
general rule which is true in almost any
domain you want to err on the side of
under promising and over delivering as
opposed to over-promising and
under-delivering now I understand this
can be a little tough to do especially
if you're new at a company and you want
to build a reputation because it really
does look good when you're able to get a
lot of quality work done really quickly
and I totally get that but you really
want to make as reasonable as possible
estimates of how long things are going
to take and that could look like just as
a general rule assuming something will
take twice as long as your first guess
about how long it'll take your client
will appreciate that in the long run and
it's a really good thing to do just for
your own sanity and your own well-being
and finally mistake number five is
wasting way too much time trying to
improve a model
now this is when you make a model and
it's not performing as well as you'd
hoped or expected so you spend hours or
days or weeks sometimes even months
trying to make this thing better now
don't get me wrong sometimes it is
appropriate to invest a lot of time into
a model and it is critically important
that you make sure you do all the
aspects of model building in a way that
sound and makes sense whether it's
feature selection pre-processing of your
actual data the sampling scheme you're
using tuning all of that is super
important however it is also really
important to acknowledge when you might
have hit a point of diminishing marginal
returns it'll often happen if you're
just trying to get a model that's
performing better that all you need is
better and more informative data having
said that it's also true sometimes your
underlying data is crap so maybe the way
that a response variable was trained is
not appropriate and if your data is crap
the model that you build is going to be
crap every single time - so I do totally
get that for a lot of people this is the
most exciting part of data science but
it's important to know when to step back
and figure out what things could
potentially lead to the biggest impact
overall and now one more thing that I
want to bring up this is a contender for
one of the worst things that you can do
but I'm not including it with all the
others because it's not the fault of the
data scientist alone and that's solving
the wrong problem in the first place now
this could happen because you're
building a model that the client isn't
interested in and is not going to use it
could be you're working in a team to
build a product when there's no market
interest in it there are countless
examples of it but solving the wrong
problem is ultimately the thing which is
going to cost you the most time and it's
going to have the biggest impact on your
business so just always keep that in
mind so all these things are things that
I have done in my data science career
and then identify it at sample
down the road that they were mistakes
after the fact I've tried to be
conscientious about them in my future
work just learn from them and not repeat
the exact same mistakes that's really
what's going to be important in the long
run and for me personally it's been one
of the biggest sources of growth that
I've had in my career so far so thanks
for watching this I hope you found it
educational drop me a comment below to
let me know if you've ever done any of
these things or if there are any other
glaring mistakes that you've made in
your own work until next time Richard on
data